so one of the most
counterintuitive
ideas
is the idea
of cyber daleks
the idea that there's a connection a
relationship between
psychedelics and cybernetics
even though psychedelics are more
associated with spiritual experiences
and transcendence of the self
and cybernetics associated with
computers or technological hardware
the truth is that
psychedelics and cybernetics are
intimately intertwined
in fact there was an article once that
called google the first psychedelically
informed superpower
so from where
does this idea originate that where what
is the
what is the origin story right for
the seeds of
the intersection of psychedelics and
cybernetics well for this you have to go
back to the 1960s in silicon valley you
know the bay area near san francisco we
were in the middle of the psychedelic
revolution everybody was tuning in
turning on dropping out the whole thing
was happening people were
obliterating their limiting beliefs and
their sense of self you know i think
timothy leary said you experience the
fresh the hardly bearable ecstasy of
direct energy exploding on your nerve
endings but what happens is that when
engineers
and other technologists and material
thinkers and mathematicians had these
ecstatic experiences their interpretive
frameworks were more technical rather
than seeing the grade beyond some
evidence of a spiritual realm they
realize we already live in a world
that's infinitely mysterious where
forces are at play that we cannot see we
cannot touch we cannot smell and we
cannot see
right and so from then they realize if
we can free our minds from our limiting
beliefs maybe we can free ourselves
through our technical proficiency in
similar ways
to the degree that now our ideas can be
recorded in silica the contents of our
minds can be exteriorized our tools and
technologies are engineering miracles
right they are they are the a reflection
of what timothy leary or rather terence
mckenna called the coral reef-like
animal right the human being has become
the extruder of technological material
can you get any more psychedelic than
that we take in matter of low
organization it goes through the filters
of the human mind then we extrude space
shuttles and iphones we engender
complexity we rework materials so that a
hunk of junk becomes an iphone a device
made of plastic and metal that can
communicate us with minds across the
planet we can bring a musical soundscape
you know a perfect song to frame a
moment that seems to be showered by the
sky we can summon the song we can direct
it into being like a dream
we can craft our waking dreams and
mediate our own realities we have
uploaded ourselves into a matrix only to
reveal that we already live in a matrix
that can be programmed through our
technical proficiency
and the digital revolution and the
virtual revolution is spilling over into
the biotechnological revolution and then
we're going to be patterning biology
which is also software right which is
also a subversively psychedelic idea
that all is programmable and everything
can be upgraded and everything can be
re-tuned and everything can be
transformed and then nanotechnology
which sees the material world as
programmable atoms another psychedelic
idea so when leary said you experienced
the fresh the hardly bearable ecstasy of
direct energy exploding on your nerve
endings that has been made manifest by
digital technology virtual metaverses
biotechnological mrna vaccines and
eventually nanotechnology creating
buildings that self-assemble we are
living in a magical world
and if you could time-lapse human
progress it would look like our minds
our consciousnesses the imagination is
spilling out of us and we are
actualizing the human imagination we are
designing the world and ourselves into
being right
we are literally a thinking stratum of
the earth that is willing itself into
existence but that's already what
biology is so it's biology becoming
aware of itself which is also a
psychedelic insight when tim doody said
that psychedelic experiences
recontextualizes the self into a
marvelous conduit in a timeless hole we
are a marvelous conduit in a timeless
hole from which molecules and meanings
flow from neurons to nebula and back
again in ones and zeros in dna code and
in programmable atoms my friends and
that's
what makes the technological revolution
in singularity we're living through
psychedelic it is psychedelic
cyberdelics is where psychedelics and
cybernetics meet that's the cyberdelic
revolution in the world we live in today
[Music]